Congrats to youtube user brah or draw
for being the first winner in our
infinity war blu-ray giveaway shoot me
an email in the email in my description
and I'll get you your copy for the rest
of you don't worry the giveaway still
continues I'm still giving away a few
more copies of infinity war on blu-ray
all you have to do to enter the giveaway
is subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero so check out the
latest video from Tom Holland outside
the brothers trust ok thank the amazing
support has been incredible awesome
stuff like this go to my Instagram
account go on the link on my bio go on
the brothers trust website and you'll
get to come to say hang out with me and
it'll be amazing and for the record I do
all my own stunts all of my own stunts I
never ever stop always always me Tom
Cruise does a similar thing I'm the same
always where do you go okay so this is
Tom Holland doing his thing sharing
videos of the set like he normally does
and while he's kind of doing a promotion
and trying to be funny at the same time
this might actually tell us a little bit
more about spider-man far from home
there was a rumor going around before
far from home started shooting and that
rumor it was that at some point in time
during the movie spider-man would fight
hydro-man and as you saw in the video
that Tom Holland took himself his stunt
double gets hit with a huge wave now
this could be just a normal ordinary
wave but look how his stunt double gets
hit back
that clearly looks like an attack and
take a look at the scenery it does not
look like he's anywhere near the ocean
it definitely looks like he's at a canal
somewhere we know that this is being
filmed in Europe and in some places in
Europe there are a lot of canals and I
have never seen a canal produce a wave
at least not like that before so I'm
going to say that this is definitely
some sort of an attack
so in the comics there's this guy named
Morris bench he's a crewman on a cargo
ship and while he's on this cargo ship
here comes the Moore and spider-man and
they start fighting and he ends up
getting knocked over seized by
spider-man when he falls overseas he
gets exposed to this experimental
generator and what it does is
essentially turn his whole entire body
into water and ever since that moment he
seeks revenge on spider-man this is the
first actual evidence that we have to
back up the rumor that hydro-man will be
in spider-man far from home to me this
video certainly does make it look like
we're going to see hydro man and
spider-man far from home I don't think
he's going to be the main villain I
still think it's going to be Mysterio
but they've been known to put more than
one villain in the spider-man movies and
there's also been the rumors that we'll
see some sort of sinister six in the
movie so maybe he's one of them what do
you all think about this new video from
Tom Holland do you think this is proof
that we're going to see hydro man and
spider-man far from home let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
another reminder that the giveaway is
still going on I'll still be giving away
a few more copies of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]